when they have power they violate the
rules left and right but when we get
power we don't play by their rules now
there's a growing movement on the right
i would say it's led by a guy named
jesse kelly there is a growing movement
of the right that says when we get power
we will double down on that because that
is now that what he is calling the new
right when we get power
look they're trying to not abolish the
filibuster and in people like joe
manchin are trying no and christian
cinema senator from arizona we're not
going to abolish the filibuster it's
part of our history
if we get patent if the right gets power
in 2022 absolutely abolish the
filibuster and torture these people yeah
change all of the rules and take all of
the power and crush your enemies that
there i don't agree with that i'm just
saying that's what the new right they're
scared because i think it was harry reid
who changed the rules yeah and so that
they said you will rule the day and they
did they did and look they look what
they got they got gorsuch they got uh um
the other guy and and and when the third
one
it was my memory they got gorsuch and
they got kavanaugh and they got um
uh amy coney back yeah yeah yeah did you
did you see this story check this out
from the guardian yeah to protect the
supreme court's legitimacy a
conservative justice should step down
if presidents do not get to replace
justices in election year then coney
barrett's confirmation is illegitimate
there you go presidents do then
gorsuch's is illegitimate you can't have
it both ways these they they they
operate on lies the only way lawrence
douglas is able to convince people of
this stuff is by omitting key
information notably that it is not about
replacing a just an election year
mitch mcconnell was specifically talking
about if you do not control the senate
they will not confirm your appointee and
we would be wasting our time by having
everyone sit around and then vote no
republicans are not going to approve
garland for you it was garland right
right for obama so they were so he was
like you don't have the senate you do
not have the votes for confirmation the
country is not unified when it came to
amy coney barrett and gorsuch it was or
cody better specifically is that they
had the presidency and the senate so
they were able to do it
it's that simple
they operate on lies
they use false arguments and that's how
they maintain control and don't forget
when when when mcconnell first said that
according to the new york times hillary
clinton had a 97 chance of winning
hillary clinton although she would
probably deny this hillary clinton
probably when that happened was like i
agree with that because she was
convinced with 97 chance she was gonna
win and she wanted to appoint her own
justice to the supreme court she
probably secretly and her team were like
that's awesome yeah let's let's hold the
merrick garland why didn't we get to
pick because we're gonna win so much so
they had ordered fireworks right she was
gonna win
i remember that election yeah it's a day
to remember a lot of people are sharing
um a new report that cern large hadron
collider is gonna be firing up again and
i don't know if you all know this but
didn't didn't they fire up on 2016
smashing particles together or whatever
when they found the higgs boson no i
don't know but the the joke conspiracy
is that they accidentally warped us into
an alternate reality or something
somehow donald trump became president
and all that stuff and uh and now
they're doing it again and who knows
what's gonna happen but uh this is this
is the state of the country where the
democrats uh
the establishment media are duplicitous
they manipulate they deceive they use
fake arguments
and i'm no fan of the republican party i
think they do nothing you you literally
have republicans
here's what happens
democrats are like we would like to
strip the rights away from law-abiding
citizens in this country and republicans
go no wait don't and they say well you
guys are at don't we're at strip their
rights how about we strip half of their
rights and republicans go okay good
competition for them yeah yeah yeah this
is how
that was so bad so i i don't know about
you know you were just mentioning that
when about abolishing the filibuster
yeah that when republicans get in do it
abolish filibuster and then just trample
over democrats i don't want to see that
happen i'm saying that's what people are
saying right right yeah but yeah so i i
think there's obviously people saying
let's do let's go nuclear i think that
contributes to the gradual decline of
the us system of governance and the
reason we're seeing democrats like joe
biden bypass the legislature and supreme
court and def in violation of our norms
and law is because they're tired they
want to get things done they want to do
things they can't
this country used to move slowly
you used to have to like ride on
horseback to go to dc to cast a vote and
and policy moved slowly now they're like
it must be done now yeah okay here's
what i want to see lauren bobert
would you please
keep consistently filing bills to repeal
the nfa
can we get marjorie taylor green as well
thomas massey rand paul all you guys
repeal the nfa give me a good reason why
they would why not seriously why not
national firearms act no no get rid of
it we have the right to keep and bear
arms i'm not saying that we would
legitimately repeal the nfa but at the
very least the terms of the argument
should not be no wait don't it should
literally be like okay democrats you're
at gun control we're at complete
deregulation of all gun laws in the
country how about we agree upon will
only ban fully auto
how about we we
we're going to repeal the nfa and then
you could start arguing from our
position on gun rights they don't do
that republicans never do this no they
they buy into the common sense gun rules
right and that's just what you do you
just rephrase it as common sense gun
protection common sense gun restrictions
and
now we've we've ex we've ceded to the
argument that these are common sense as
opposed to saying this isn't common
sense this is unconstitutional but it's
not even i don't mean to make it about a
gun rights thing and be like guns i'm
not paying the table i'm saying quite
literally when the democrats go
universal healthcare the republicans
don't go deregulation of government
healthcare they go no wait don't yeah
and then the democrats say okay you're
at stop and we're at government
healthcare how about we meet halfway and
do you know public option yeah which is
most of the time what happens and then
they get most of what they wanted anyway
i would like to go back the democrats
tell people it's inverted yeah that
we're helpless the republicans are
stopping so much more i would just like
to go back to single issue votes like
the water bottle i can't understand why
we can't get people in congress who will
say this is the bill and it's a page and
a half and here's how much it costs and
it goes through the appropriate
committee and it goes through markup and
it makes it to instead we get these
monster monster monster bills we don't
even do the appropriation process right
right we don't and that's why people
like
joe biden's brother get 1.5 trillion
dollar contracts because it's
it's rolled up into the the defense
reauthorization act and and
no one knows where it is what's the
appropriation process the way it should
work is that if it depends upon what the
issue is say it's transportation right
uh we want to build a bridge between
these two states federal government has
to get a job it has to go through the
transportation subcommittee the
department of transportation has to make
their proposal transportation
subcommittee works it up appropriation
says how much do we have in the treasury
and then they those two then together
bring it to the floor for the larger
vote and then you gotta whip the votes
and say you're gonna vote for my bridge
and i'll vote for your bridge but if you
vote for my bridge and and then the
senate actually works but what's
happening now how's that different we
are just bypassing all that you know
what's happening the the the
transportation committee will have a
markup on racism and the in the
transportation department and they'll
talk about the inherent racism of of of
of the taxi cabs and they'll say if you
inherit racism p buddha judge in his
confirmation talked about how you we
must acknowledge as a country that most
of our infrastructure was built on
racism and they say if you don't vote
for my bill you hate the troops you're
racist
all that stuff
so then they'll take your bridge and
they'll roll it into everything well you
know where your bridge is it's going to
come out in the 3.5 trillion dollar oh
along with everyone else's little yeah
you're talking about appropriating funds
for individual projects within a large
yeah wouldn't that be great
and then and then the committee says how
much does the transportation department
actually need next year what are all the
projects we have what do they actually
need blah blah blah but we don't do that
we're just like ah we just make up
numbers you know how i've described
what's going on the culture war in the
past i've said it's like imagine there's
a big whirlpool that's spinning around
and we're all in it
and over time it's getting tighter and
and compressing and spinning faster and
faster and faster that's because we're
getting lower in the pool as we go down
it gets tighter and faster maybe maybe
we're circling the drain that's a good
way to put it i think uh
in the in in the real world the the the
reality is that the information is
circulating faster and faster
so the analogy i love the most is
imagine it's you know the revolutionary
era and the founding fathers are like
we're declare independence and they fold
up the letter and they pour the wax on
it and stamp it and they hand it to the
carrier who rides on horseback to the
boat who puts it on the boat who then
gets the boat on the water for three
months to make it back to the king of
england and then in that three months
have you sent the letter you're sitting
there you're working the crops or you're
you're having meetings and discussions
about independence and then the king the
boat finally lands it takes a few days
to make it to the from the port to the
to the to the to the king into
parliament and then the king reads it
and says oh he had and then he drafts a
letter and he says i reject this we're
sending in troops and then three months
after that
that's how things used to be you would
say we're going to have a policy
position how many times like if they
were actually going to go to dc and
actually have a vote they had to
physically go there they'd have
discussions and they weren't hearing all
of this stuff all over the place like if
you lived in virginia and then someone
came down from new york you were hearing
things for the first time up in new york
we had a damn breach and now we've got
water flooding these areas we are not
securing our and then you'd be like i
didn't know that happened you guys ever
see the movie news of the world with tom
hanks no
it was a it was a reconstruction era and
he has newspapers from different cities
and he travels around the south with old
newspapers
charging people a dime so they can sit
down as he reads the news that's how
things used to be today what happens is
someone goes on twitter and says abolish
the police and then someone else says i
agree aoc why aren't you abolishing the
police and literally within like 10
minutes she's like i as a representative
think we should abolish the police i'm
not saying literally i'm saying as an
example so we're moving
instantaneously
and then because
she can't get it done in a session
because we're still using this old
system of like you know ian you're
probably like this we're not we're
meeting in person instead of doing
things digitally then people demand if
we can all see the problem why can't we
click a button and fix it why are we
waiting so long for this and then when
it's not getting done they say let's
just bypass the rules of legit of the
legislature joe biden says let me just
rule by executive order and bypass the
supreme court which told me what i'm
doing is illegal but i don't care i'll
do it anyway because we demand instant
satisfaction
whole system is about to burst it's
burst already and now we're just waiting
for the light to reach our eyes but even
the example you used which i liked of uh
the guy from virginia heard heard about
the dam breach from new york
if that was happening in real time
probably the back of his head was like
well
sorry in new york but i represent
virginia yep we don't even have that
anymore proof of that and you mentioned
our beloved alexandria ocasio-cortez
um when she was caught masculist at that
ball a couple weeks ago and her one her
initial response was well like as the
congresswoman from new york like i'm
there for cultural reasons but it's also
my constituency and you say no that was
in manhattan you are queens in the bronx
that museum isn't you're like there is
no constitutional reason for you to say
i represent new york but in her mind i'm
fairly convinced she thinks i am the
congresswoman of new york yep you wish
you were the congress person who i think
would be jerry nadler if i'm right but i
could be wrong i think that's his dress
that you would love for him to call up
and be like uh i'm sorry child like
that's my district
don't talk about my district but that's
what we do now we have members of of of
congress who are passing laws senators
who are passing laws about states they
don't even represent we want to close
anwar patty murray washington i've told
the senators from alaska to say pass a
bill that says apples are illegal
consider considering because that's
washington consider this it's back in
the uh let's let's say you know 1800 at
some point early 1800s and someone from
virginia goes to congress and someone
from new york comes down and says we had
a damn breach and he says that i
represent virginia i don't know i don't
tell you you know we want to make sure
we can help our our you know our friends
in in new york so we'll see what we can
do
today you'll you'll get uh i'll avoid
naming the specific companies but you'll
get a major corporation
going to europe in virginia and say vote
for our bill so we can gut the natural
spring waters in new york yeah you see
it wasn't as easy to transfer money back
then and to communicate as quickly so
you'd have to have a major corporations
spokesman go down to virginia to lobby
specifically
possible it was done it was a lot harder
yeah nowadays you get a linkedin message
you get you get you got a list you get a
bunch of phone calls and emails you get
texts non-stop and there's a guy saying
look you don't care about new york right
you represent virginia great here's what
we're gonna do we we think we should be
able to harvest all the natural spring
water from upstate new york there's
people who live there but don't worry
they're not gonna they're not gonna
sweat it one bit besides there's only
100 people up there we are going to make
substantial contributions to your
political action committees it's going
to be fantastic you'll love it when you
announce your reelection or when you
announce your election
or a wink wink nudge nudge and then all
of a sudden somebody in virginia doesn't
care about new york says i'm in favor of
the clean water uh usurpion act uh the
theft of water act i think it would be
great if we could share the water with
the country yeah and that's really just
you're bought and paid for yeah like
george carlin i think it was he said we
should put the patches on all over all
over their suits yeah so we know who's
sponsoring them i i just i
i don't think i will ever run for office
i just wish those who represented their
areas had so much more pride and sense
of ownership and sense of responsibility
and sense of territorialness so that if
another senator or congress person was
trying to pass
laws or whatever about my area the
response is like no no no this is turf
warfare you know and and and it just
bothers me that
everyone thinks they are the senator of
the country
and there are great examples of that
lindsey graham spends half his time in
afghanistan i i am here because i am the
senator you're the senator from south
carolina a not
hugely significant state no offense to
south carolinians who are watching
lovely state have vacation there many
times but like
you're the senator from south carolina
stay in south carolina care deeply about
south carolina but what these guys do is
they run for office and and republicans
i think sometimes are even more guilty
of this and democrats ted cruz has been
senator of america marco rubio has been
senator of america since the day they
got into office they get their funding
from all over the country and a lot of
time their constituents hates them yep
but but they raised so much money on the
national level that they keep winning
but the you know it was fascinating the
last ted cruz race where he almost lost
to beto o'rourke which is a whole other
thing running for governor now uh
natural-born texans
uh he lost the vote of natural-born
texans he won the republican vote of
people who moved to texas texans didn't
like ted cruz thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time